Let's find where on our graph we have x equals negative 4. So I'll count over,
negative 1, negative 2, negative 3, negative 4, on the x axis. And then slide
down to the graph. What is that y coordinate? Maintain this vertical position,
but sliding over to the y axis, we can see that this is halfway between negative
16 negative 18, so y is equal to negative 17 when X equals negative 4. That
means that this point right here on the graph is negative 4, negative 17. When Y
equals negative 9, you can start on our Y axis and go all the way down to
negative 9, and then slide over to the graph. Keep the same horizontal position
of my pencil tip and slide up to the X axis. That is half way between negative 1
and negative 2, so that means that this point right here must be negative 1 and
a half, negative 9. So when y is negative 9, x is equal to negative 1.5. Of
course, you could also write this in fractional form if you wanted to. Of
course, to make sure that our graph and the conclusions that we've drawn for it
are totally accurate, we can always plug in these values to our equation, to
figure out the value of the other variable.